what's that believe nation it's been a
while since I gave you an update on
what's happening with my new book the
top ten rules of success and I thought
let's give these guys a sneak peek as to
what's coming so I've been working on
this book for maybe about a year maybe a
little bit under a year slowly slowly
slowly kind of working my way through
and making some progress and then
suddenly on my vacation I decided while
on the cruise ship I'm gonna get this
book out December 6 because it's the
one-year anniversary of my first book
you're one word and he just felt like a
good date to put it out and that meant I
had to hustle really really really
really really really hard to get it
ready for you guys so I spent a good
chunk of my vacation and on the cruise
ship doing my book and luckily I have a
very supportive wife who was on board
during that process well you know was
sleeping I was working on the book while
Lina was working out at the gym I was
working on the book and basically any
Sparrow and I had I was working on the
book so the good news is I got the book
done I got the first draft done I got it
all finished I had 50 of the top ten
people that I profiled on my channel the
50 most popular famous entrepreneurs and
condense their top ten rules that's 500
rules down into one book and then
distilled that into the top ten most
common rules that keep coming up over
and over and over and over again put it
into one but really excited me about the
book was I was putting two ideas per
page so it might be a forty minute long
video but you'll be able to go through
all ten rules in five pages so I wanted
to really condense it down and the goal
is for the readers to read one page a
day don't read the whole book you're
gonna plow through it you won't learn as
much read one page a day you get to
genius ideas and people who've done an
amazing thing
and then apply it to your business
that's important because it's so easy to
get motivated it's so easy to get
inspired so easy to be on fire one day
and then you wake up the next day and
poof that motivation inspiration is gone
and so I wanted to find an easy easy
easy way to be able to hit that with you
every single day how easy is it to read
one page a day and then think about
applying it to your business so this
became the end result I made a book I
printed up 30 different versions 30
different copies and I gave it out to
some friends some entrepreneurs I'm not
entrepreneurs in Toronto and asked them
to review the book to highlight it to
mark it up I give them two weeks notice
and they had basically two weeks to get
through all 500 rules and tell me what
they liked what they didn't like give me
some suggestions for how to improve it
everyone it's Lily how do I know Evan
Evans my superstar mentor and what I'm
excited about this book is I'm excited
because of Evan because Evan wrote this
book and his last thought your one word
had a significant impact in my life and
I'm really excited to see how this is an
impact in my life my name is Rob doc
Dino aka DJ duck from China dance salsa
that's how I know Evan we've been
friends for about six to eight years and
we met at Toronto dance salsa and I got
his latest book it's called the top ten
rules for success you know I'm saying so
I'm excited to read this book
learn something learn how to be
successful in life and help those people
to be successful as well
you know because I got my own business
and I'm making it successful to help
people being successful DJ duck how
about thanks everyone
Jay Wong here from the inner changemaker
podcast and I'm so excited to be diving
into heavens a new book we actually met
because of his first book when he came
on my podcast last year and we were
diving into your one word so I'm really
excited to see what the top ten rules
for success is gonna be there's someone
else with my favorite mentors are
inherent so I can't wait to actually
dive in and see what this is all about
hey guys my name is tallish and my
e-commerce consultants in Toronto I have
known Evan for going on 15 years now
yeah it's about 15 years now you should
see the face he's making right now
beyond the camera time we have no never
for long term and it's always been
inspirational for my work and a lot of
things and I had a chance to read his
first bucket I know in my hands I have
top ten rules of success and I'm really
excited because I think this
still a lot of work that he's been doing
on YouTube and a lot of information has
been champing it's got a lot of wealth
of information out there but this is
like a distillation of tendrils it's all
Federal's
so excited hey there our mark Drager and
I'm with Fanta
I've known Evan for 10 years now a
little bit over that and I'm really
excited to get into this book because
I'm a huge fan of the top ten rules to
success video series and now I have this
all in writing I can get into it I can
start crossing stuff out and yeah hi I'm
max Callas from smarter leads and I've
known Evan for over 10 years now I met
him at it networking about a business
event and I'm excited about this new
book because I am excited to learn how
to model from the Masters and Evan has
convinced this into quite a book hi my
name is Roger Pierce I'm a small
business expert my company is Pierce
content marketing we create small
business content for big brands and
smaller businesses I've known having
Carmichael for many years we met through
entrepreneur circles and sort of a
network of small business experts we
stay in touch with I'm really excited to
read this new book I've always been a
big follower of Evans videos and I know
the book is based on some of our
successful videos and it contains
already a lot of my entrepreneur heroes
in the world so I'm really looking
forward to reading it and picking up to
my advice I really like the idea of
having a test audience it's not
something that standardly done in the
publishing world for whatever crazy
reason it really worked well in my first
book you're one word where I cut out
half the book based off the feedback of
the 30 people to keep it - and since it
worked out so well I thought I got to do
it again for this one so then last
weekend I took all of these books and
combined all the notes into this this is
my one master copy where I basically
went through and underlined everything
people like check some of the comments
of people highlighted basically keeping
track as you go through the entire book
of the things that people like all 30
versions into one master copy and what
I'm doing now is taking that one master
copy and bringing it to the actual word
doc to put all the changes in to make
improvements to make it better to make
it exciting to give you guys the best of
the best of the
I've also been working with a number of
designers to help me make a book cover
because I just threw together a template
for the first one and I wanted to cover
that I really loved I didn't love that
your one word book I've I've talked
about that before I wasn't a huge huge
fan of it and I wanted one that I really
loved this time and we've also been
adding a ton of graphics to the inside
of the book and working with a bunch of
designers to make all that happen it's
been a ton a ton a ton of work but
absolutely worth it and so where to stay
now is I'm actually cutting ten of the
people from the book we're gonna go with
40 people the most popular ones of the
most popular ones basically the ones
that the people in my test audience like
the other ten that we're cutting I'm
pulling out into a special e bonus so
for those of you who buy the book make
sure you email in your receipt or a
picture view of the book and you'll get
the other ten as a bonus and now I was
just finishing off the final details
getting the cover finalized getting it
approved uploaded everything the Amazon
putting on Creed's basic and the Kindle
eBook version ready all of the tiny
little things that have to get done to
make a book launch go December 6 is
still the timeline is still the goal I
hope we can make it thicker is Christ
and I wanted to keep you guys in the
loop so thank you guys for all the love
all the support all the suggestions I'm
really excited to launch this thing as I
read each page in the book it gets me
excited that gives me new ideas it gives
me new motivation inspiration to apply
things to the things that I'm doing on
my youtube channel to my businesses that
I'm involved with and I'm so so so so so
excited to be able to bring it to you
I think the environment you create
matters the routines you create matter I
think my youtube channel has been a
great source of inspiration for a lot of
people as a daily reminder to look at
the world maybe a slightly different way
to bring more success into your mindset
and I'm hoping that the book just
extends that out by reading one page a
day you get inspiration wisdom and great
ideas from some of the greatest minds
about the most success in the world and
that has to seep into your brain to help
you become the best version of yourself
so I'll keep you posted as I continue to
make progress I'll continue to launch
other bonuses and other ideas if you
guys have suggestions thoughts feedback
for me as I get
at the launch date six let me know
leaving the comments below thank you
guys so much for your love I really
appreciate it I believe in you hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love guys
I'll see you soon volume you have the
most important word ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple that would
be like a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details